one day I was getting a haircut and my
girl Jess who's one of my best friends
she's she's my stylist and she had David
come over and she said she said Mabel
might want to look at this and I was
missing a big patch of hair in the back
of my head and then she started looking
around and I was missing several big
patches in the back of my head anyway
long story short after going to some
doctors it turns out that I had I was
diagnosed with alopecia areata which is
basically an autoimmune disease where
your your white blood cells start
attacking your hair follicles they don't
know why
so they chalk it up to stress now I was
under a tremendous amount of stress
suddenly I was getting hate like like
endless relentless hate from the good
guys the the Liberals the progressives
the tolerant decent people I was getting
a tremendous amount of hate from them
from my side and I probably wasn't
dealing with it the best way possible
you know kind of expressed it here when
I do these things with you but generally
in life I'm like a little more calm and
cool and collected and I don't share
every thought that I have all the time
and I'm not the most overly emotional
person let's say which I think does lead
to good to a good ability to interview
somebody in a calm manner but anyway I
started losing huge chunks of hair and
then it started moving to the top of my
head and then we tried steroid
injections courtesans a whole bunch of
stuff and nothing was working and then I
ended up going on a really experimental
treatment which I talked about in the
book that basically causes it's in
effect it's like putting poison ivy on
your head and the hope is that the white
blood cells that are attacking your hair
follicles instead of attacking the
follicles will attack the reaction and
then your hair will grow back anyway I
had absolutely horrific reaction to it
because you're basically putting your
stuff you're allergic to on your body
and at the height now so now the show is
blowing up are you like I'm on the way
up like I'm at the beginning of my
success and I you know I'm being
recognized and I'm being invited places
and all this stuff and things are really
working we're making a little money
things are chugging along and suddenly
I'm dealing with this horrific
affliction that actually at one point I
had lost so much hair on the top of my
head that like I had this like strip
like right here basically the front
strip
and I was doing all sorts of crazy
and I was putting you know blank black
powder to cover up spots and then I was
also one of the side effects that I was
I was insanely hot all the time so you
know we're in hot studio lights and I'd
be dripping and sweating and I was
really bloated and like I look back on
videos you can look at some of the
videos that we did in the fall of the
fall and and in early the fall of 2015
and in early 2016 and I look like a mess
like I do not look like myself I look
exhausted and you know big bags under my
eyes and and it was not good it was
terrible actually he was and I really
thought about quitting at one point and
then I tell the story about I was really
thinking about I was like I don't know
that I can do this maybe we'll just do a
radio show maybe I won't do anything
anymore and again this is just as I'm
like on the way up
long story short over the last couple
years I've completely changed my diet
changing my workout thing I mostly do
paleo I do some something called PRP
which is platelet-rich plasma which they
take your blood out of yourself they
spin it in a centrifuge and inject it
back into you and I do that like once
every two months or so and I do have one
or two tiny little spots but this is
this is all my hair it's all real and I
do but I do have one or two tiny little
spots and anyway I mention all of this
just to tell you that when you have when
you fight the mob
weird things happen I've talked to some
other people that have fought the mob
some public people and they've told me
some some that they've had to deal
with or what it's done to their own
personal relationships or this and that
but I would say there is nothing to not
be yourself to not fight for what you
believe in is a far worse it's a far
worse sentence than losing a little hair
or something like that